hey guys Ryan here I'm gonna be checking
out the final trailer for Mad Max fury
road
I love these trailers I like the
original three and I'm even interested
in the game let's check this out on a
red band trailer
she looks good without ya
3000 gallons of guzzoline just like you
asked
my name is max you said a few vehicles
in pursuit we count three war parties
yeah well I got unlucky
world is reduced to a single instant
survive
so I exist in this wasteland hunted by
scavengers what are you doing praying to
her anyone that's listening they're
sitting on 2,000 horsepower of nitrous
to the war machine
what gets through this
he done this before
oh what a day what a lovely day
every one of those trailers gets these
nips really hard Wow
[ __ ] I've reviewed so many trailers of
this now much more you should say Madi
just like [ __ ] let's watch it again
that [ __ ] was awesome it looks so like
gritty
love it heart is gonna rock it's all
here
3000 gallons of guzzoline just like you
asked
one name is max a few vehicles in
pursuit we count three war parties yeah
well I got unlucky
world is reduced to a single instinct
survive
love the practical effects the designers
so air man music it's so good
so I exist in this wasteland piloted by
scavengers
I didn't even get it all
what are you doing praying to anyone
that christening
they're sitting on 10,000 horsepower
tonight requested war machine
he done this before
oh what a day what a lovely day
[ __ ]
I am so there opening night
Avengers first week of May and then
third week of May Mad Max holy [ __ ] that
is I want to watch like I want to play
that trailer slowly and just looking at
frame by frame
Tom art he's gonna kill it in that role
man god damn that was something that was
something anyway you can check out my
other reactions where I actually like
where view the trailer a little bit but
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
trying to get product placements I want
to be able to tweet about dildos and
then get sponsored by a dildo company
your mind Sonny what a lovely died that
was the worst impression hey guys
love your channel Ryan you are the most
funniest guy I know and keep up the good
work you Ryan
Jerry ELISA and Dan all of you are the
best Germain you're the best
looking at your photo you are a little
kid so time for my fatherly advice I
would recommend starting now at a young
age
watch the hardest r-rated movies you can
watch like Mad Max fury road it's rated
R for disturbing images watch movies
like the Saw franchise you know check
out the movie mania the human centipede
you want to start watching those now so
you become immune to it so by the time
you're older it won't bother you or it
just shuts down your emotions and turns
you into a bloodthirsty serial killer
either way it's gonna be entertaining
for me